a company that has a net of 10 could be
worth like 80. is what you're saying
yeah 30 million Top Line 10 million
bottom line we'll just use that as the
as the number everything depends on the
churn within the business it's two big
pieces one is how big is the market how
sticky is the revenue so if we're
gobbling up market share and it just
keeps compounding and stacking on stuff
because everyone keeps loving the thing
that we sell then it's going to be
tremendously valuable if it's a much
more transactional company then we're
going to get a much lower multiple you
know the range is huge there I would say
it's probably like six to twelve for a
company that was doing 10 million it'd
probably be like you know maybe eight to
twelve you know a certain percentage
that be rolled in equity a certain
percentage that would be seller finance
certain percentage that would be you
know Consulting back and then a certain
percentage that would be cash you know
all those things added together might be
the 8X but you may be cash portion might
only be five or whatever so we're
talking a multiple of ebitda right now
or yeah